[Music]
[Applause]
today
is a big day
because we are now officially at the
halfway mark of this pregnancy today is
the day i turned 20 weeks and we're
heading over to our doctor's appointment
and this is technically the appointment
where they would tell us what the sex of
the baby is but because we're trying to
wait until the baby's born we're not
going to find out i'm also crossing my
fingers
that if it's a boy we don't see anything
because we might see stuff if it's a boy
are you going to be subconsciously
looking for it
probably i don't know
what i think i don't know
you know what's funny um so i posted uh
like our last ultrasound thing that we
had at 12 weeks i posted on instagram
there were people saying like it's
actually even here in this vlog um there
were people saying like it's a boy it's
definitely a boy definitely see
you know uh boy parts at 12 weeks so it
was like if there is anything between
their legs it's just
either their leg that you're getting it
mixed up with
or they're the umbilical cord because
they're at 12 weeks there's no genitalia
that's really like visible like that
early
but now
at 20 weeks
there is
and so i don't know like we might be
seeing um
like an umbilical cord
or it might be
uh yeah it's an umbilical cord a boy
part they'll go forward
i don't know
but i don't know and then i have no clue
what a girl would look like
i know you've never seen one on an
ultrasound so i don't know but
everyone's saying it's a boy now like
everyone that i've come in contact with
that's talking about
whether or not it's a boy or girl
they're like i have a feeling it's a boy
[Music]
everyone was saying girl well everyone
was saying that they want us to have a
girl because we don't have a girl
but yeah i've been seeing a lot of boy
predictions but on my instagram recently
there's a lot of girl predictions so who
knows i don't know we don't know
my own personal prediction is that we're
having a boy that's just because
the way that this belly is forming you
know like i don't know if you guys know
that well like old wives tell like if
you're having a boy the belly like pops
out and it's just like a tiny little
basketball in front of your body and
then with the girl and the belly ends up
like growing like more sideways like
more wider and to me
i mean this is a really bad position
because i'm sitting down and it looks
pretty wide right now but to me this
this belly has been forming
into a koi belly so
i don't know also like you know 20 weeks
now five months
it's like i don't know my belly's kind
of
there's people saying that it's a small
belly they're like oh at five months
like okay
like it's it's a decent size i don't
know especially because the recent post
that i
uploaded on instagram too where i was
like sitting on a bench and the way i
was sitting like my belly was really
like popping out a lot so people were
like whoa we have a big belly but
i don't know it's like i feel like it's
kind of the same situation like when i
was pregnant with isaac like i i'm
pretty much
the same like the same belly size at
this amount of weeks like it didn't
really pop out very much
but i am wearing my maternity yoga pants
that came in
so see they're kind of
they're kind of loose
yeah in the vlog where we went to
solvang
you were saying how it was just like so
uncomfortable for you and you're like i
need to go shopping i need to go
shopping
i finally went shopping i ordered these
on amazon all my clothes that i bought
for maternity wear fit me really loose
because i don't have like a really big
belly yet so it's not really holding on
to it
yeah grow into it so we're gonna see the
baby again today i'm so excited i wonder
how much bigger they look if they're
gonna be moving a lot
[Music]
[Music]
and the baby was so shy according to the
technician because she wasn't able to
get one particular photo she got kind of
blurry and she wanted to get it clear
which was the heart and she's like god
it's okay um
i will just schedule you to come back
for another
session um but what they don't know is
that i'm switching doctors
this is actually my last appointment
here and we're switching over to another
place that's more like
midwife based care so here it's more
like
ob gyn like medical doctor based care i
realized like after coming here a couple
times i'm like this ain't my thing i
want to go to a midwife so we're
actually switching but they don't
so anyway
but it was really cool though because we
told the technician that we didn't want
to know what the sexist baby was so
she's like okay i'll let you know when
to look away when i get closer to that
area so she told us so we looked away
we're like okay we don't know anything
we can't see anything and the baby was
like in a ball so
like literally like this
and then like the legs were like this so
yeah it was just really
uh hard to see
much anything like anyway but it was
really cute seeing the baby all followed
because it was like you know doing it
looked like i was doing this the entire
time with both hands like well i'm
holding the camera but like it was like
this and it was like yeah they had their
hands up too because she kept trying to
see like one of the hand like we were
able to see one hand but then the other
one like they were just like not letting
go they're just like this it was really
cute oh my god they're shiny
just like they're daddy i was reading a
book
called sapiens and they talk about how
like you can tell if someone is
introverted just right at birth if they
shy away from loud noises or they shy
away from certain things like that they
tend to be more introverted where
extroverted
babies are getting towards they look
towards these things like what's that
you know so i have a hunch or maybe our
baby might be an introverted kid and
then it's not it's not surprising
because i'm a very introverted person
and then tiff i don't know what you are
i know i'm kind of both yeah like you
show signs of both things i don't know
because i used to be
super extroverted because that's like
mexican culture like is nothing but
extroverts as long as i've ever known i
didn't even know there was such thing as
introverted people like i just didn't
compute until i met you but yeah like
after being with you for so long and
then getting accustomed to your vibe
your way of living being more
comfortable at home or whatever i'm like
yeah i kind of would rather
not
be around a lot of people just be alone
like yeah i don't know like this is
draining for you to be around people i'm
a hybrid now um is it draining it can be
yeah it's always draining for me like
without it without fail it's like if i'm
around other people not that i don't
like being around other people but it
makes me feel like okay i need a break
the next time next chance again i'm
taking a break and i just need some
quiet time that's my goal i don't think
i've ever explicitly felt that like i
need to get away i need to be alone i've
never felt that what i do feel though
it's like when i am alone and i do end
up like not being around people then i'm
like oh this is nice i don't know if
anything like of the spectrum of like
introvert extrovert i feel like i'm more
introverted now yeah than i ever was my
whole life maybe that's why we're making
an introverted baby here very
introverted baby that shied away from
this uh ultrasound yeah they're just
like
look away because it was cute because
then she would like get a good like a
good still of the actual face
and then it's like almost like they
heard us or something and as soon as
like the face was like this and they'd
go like this
maybe it's an artistic baby it's like
i'm just trying to give us the good
angles they're just like it's my first
photo shoot okay let me show you what i
got
i'm actually really excited for
is it next week next a week and a half
when we're gonna go to the new doctor
well midwife but yeah new facility to
get our care there and see like what the
difference is and because i kind of
don't like how busy this office is too
like it's cheering you out it's like a
factory exactly it feels like a factory
i'm not a fan of that and i'm not a fan
of like how we have to wait for freaking
ever when we already have our
appointment yeah so i'm looking forward
to the other facility that we're gonna
go to because they're more like we're
giving you our attention you're here
we're not gonna waste your time
we're not we don't have a ton of clients
like it's like based on
caring you know especially since i'm
gonna be attempting a vbac which is
caught which stands for vaginal birth
after cesarean because like i had a
c-section with isaac i want to have a
vaginal birth like a natural birth
it's really important to try to go to a
provider that like will support that and
here
sounds like they're kind of like and
we'll see what happens and i don't know
just yeah i didn't like it when i gave
birth to isaac um it was at a major
hospital like a big group that's really
really popular here in socal at least
usually like everyone wants to go there
and all that stuff and it's fine but i
just did not enjoy at all how they made
me feel like cattle it was just like all
right come in come out and i don't know
i just
i hated it so then now for this one i'm
like oh i'm getting the same vibes from
this place oh my god i gotta peace out
yeah follow your your instincts yeah
[Music]
you